hi there in this pie mold tutorial we're
going to look at how to model protein
protein interactions and we're going to
be doing this using the SARS Cove 2
receptor binding domain in complex with
human ace 2 angiotensin-converting
enzyme 2 which is the receptor on the
cell surface that causes recognition and
allows the virus to undergo fusion let's
go ahead and fetch this structure and
people were particularly interested in
how I modeled this because the paper
wasn't available at the time and so they
had deposited this crystal structure and
it was available and so I had to model
this by hand and so I want to show you
how I modeled it by hand but I have cool
news because the paper is now actually
available as an early preprint in nature
it's still undergoing editing but you
know in the interest of giving as people
as much information to solve these
problems as possible they pushed out the
paper so there's a draft available
online go to the PDB I use the rcsb PDB
and you can just click on the DOI for
that journal article there that document
identifier and I'll bring it right up
and you can read about it too so the
first thing I noticed was there's kind
of a symmetry here notice we have all
these beta sheets and you can see it
looks like this piece of the protein is
kind of mapped over here but flipped so
what this is is the smallest unit in the
protein and this is the smallest it's
called the asymmetric unit so these two
crystals are aligned like this and then
this this structure repeats and repeats
and repeats and so the crystallographer
gave us this piece and you can see the
asymmetry because this is flipped this
way and this is flipped this way and so
they're showing us the asymmetric unit
but what we really have going on here is
two units of the spike protein which is
here and here and then two units of ACE
two which are here and here and so I
wanted to do some work on this so I
could just show you one of these at
time and so now I'm going to show you
how I did that and how I modeled the
interaction so we'll do this without the
paper and then I'll point out one new
interaction that I learned by reading
the paper and yeah let's get to it
so let's display our sequence turn on
our sequence here and I want to do a
command first UTI l dot CBC this means
to color the protein by chain and so now
we can see there are four chains here
they're going to show up in different
colors and then I'll make it a little
bit easier for us to sift through this
and now I didn't know if it was gonna be
this chain list at first this one second
this one third something like that but
notice that we go green then blue and so
it's these two ACE proteins that are
shown first and then at the end we have
our two our pink and yellow receptor
binding domains so now this just makes
us makes it easier for us to see and I
can show and hide things appropriately
and so what I'm going to do is select
some things I want to show and select
some things I want to hide so let's go
ahead and select this first chain I'm
gonna go to the end of it shift and
click and I'm going to scroll along
because I want to just check something
out so notice our ligands are listed at
the end of the sequence here and now
they're adopting the color coding of the
chain that they're associated with so
this is just the protein sequences so we
really do have to go to the end to find
the rest of this so these are probably
the chains I'm going to hide and so I'm
gonna go ahead and take all these oops I
hit shift so let me just click away and
I'm gonna go back and I was still
holding shift
okay so shift and click to get that
whole sequence not do not press shift
and let's go find our green ligands near
the end of our sequence and get all of
those into our selection
just like that why not get the green
waters and now I'm going to rename my
selection so I can operate in on it
separately and and keep it active and so
I'm gonna call this ace one
you
okay now with all these selections made
I'll be able to show and hide things
when I want to and so let's go ahead and
hide everything for Ace 1 and hide
everything for our BD 1 and now we're
just looking at one subunit notice it's
like kind of wonky it's not on the
central axis and so let's see if I could
just maybe zoom on this protein and get
it more of more centered a little bit if
these were both a selection it would
Center in the middle of it that's kind
of convenient sometimes okay so we want
to look at the interactions and so this
a lot of this I do visually when I don't
have a sequence to work with and what
we're going to do is we can kind of
visually see where these proteins are
closed and this might give us some
information about the contacts so when I
was looking at this maybe if I turn it
this way it's a little bit easier to see
but it looks like things along this
alpha helix might be in contact and
oh maybe here on the loop of this beta
sheet
I'm on a Mac and pressing option and
click to kind of reorient that just
there's that little motion but you can
use your 3 button mouse and do similar
things now what I want to do is select
most of this alpha helix right here
thinking that you know this will be in
contact and then I want to get some of
this loop down here and this beta sheet
so I'll just start by clicking on here
and then notice the little thing lights
up we have a little blue blue light and
we can go ahead and select things that
are connected to this and fortunately
that's gonna be our alpha helix here so
I think about that far looks like it
should be in contact we could do it just
a few more for good measure doesn't
matter how much we select now we're
gonna actually have to kind of redo our
measurements later all right and then I
also saw it gets a little hard to see so
you might have to reorient this
carefully I think that some of this loop
might be contacting so I did that one
click and I see my little bar here so
let's get into that and we'll try to
select around that I'm going the wrong
direction so I was on this d-aspartic
acid residue and now let's get a little
bit of that loop that looks good
and I'm wondering I don't think this was
in my original selection for the video
but I'm wondering if there's like a
little interface right here so let's
just make sure that we get everything so
I did another little selection add to
this right here and let's just select a
few residues around here because we
might have interactions with those okay
I'm pretty satisfied that everything I
can kind of visually see that's close to
the other protein surface is now
selected so I'm going to rename my
selection um oh what do I want to call
it interface that sounds good so I did
the interface residues on this one
because it was easy to see a nice alpha
helix here and just select all of that
and now what I do to find the contact
themselves is pretty easy so we go
here's our interface selection so we can
see all that coming up actions find
polar contacts so polar contacts and I'm
going to put to any atoms and so we're
gonna see some of these are over here
we're having some different interactions
in different spots but some of these are
obviously like at the interface now and
sometimes we'll see oh yeah here's some
polar contacts within the Alpha helix
itself so we're not interested in that
and I didn't have that in my model in
the video because I'm gonna show you how
I go over this now and get the actual
contacts and I will admit this is
tedious and if you know a better way
please leave me a comment but this is
how I pick out my interactions when I
don't have a paper now I have all these
dashes so I'm gonna be able to see where
these dashes are and I'm gonna go ahead
and color this magenta because that's an
easy color for me to see so now let's go
to so we're showing our B d2 and a Stu
and what I'm gonna do first is show
lines for each of these okay so all the
little amino acid residues are sticking
out now and now for our b d2 action uh
nope show our BD to show lines and now
we have all these lines and we could do
this mapping with this so now you can
see like this stick here is contacting
this so we can see the context and we
see what's contacting and literally i go
through and hunt-and-peck for these
interface residues and I'm gonna make
them their own selection so I sometimes
find it easier to change the color a
little so let me just show you how I do
that
you could start selecting here and just
click and this will become a selection
then we can hunt for the one that it is
contacting which is here and the as we
select it'll add to the selection but
sometimes it's a little
here to see these when they have the CPK
coloring so I'm going to just kind of
stick with this color theme but go by
element and was this my yellow piece
oops no that was my blue piece color by
element and this will be our cyan and
then the RBD color by element and color
this yellow but now my residues notice
they have the ones that are shown with
all of their atoms which well has
everything right now have the color and
I think it's a little easier to see
these interactions so we'll click on our
selection and that lights up and so
we're just gonna look for all the blue
contacts to the yellow contacts now and
go ahead and click on these
and now if you make a mistake it's
really easy to make a mistake doing this
and you click on the wrong residue just
click right where you clicked again
because you can deselect I'm gonna try
to do this right but so see if I just
click again I deselect it and it takes
it out of my selection there
you
all right so I'm just trying to do kind
of a final visual inspection to see if
there's any pink lines that are between
the blue residues and the yellow
residues that I haven't quite found yet
but I think I'm getting close so yeah
this is tedious it's it's best to kind
of stay zoomed in while you do it and
you do have to kind of hunt around and
look for things but you will get the
polar contacts this way there is oh
here's one I missed so I missed this
yellow right here and yeah I know this
is tedious but this is this is how I did
it and put it together to get the
hydrogen bonding networks at least four
yeah cool and I don't think I had this
these interactions in the original video
so that's really great
all right and I think well for the
teaching purposes I think this
illustrates the purpose of this and so
now I'm going to rename this to
interface residues and so you'll notice
it's really really busy now with all
these um the lines on here the lines are
for every single atom of the amino acid
and so you know every single amino acid
is now shown so let's go back to these
and we're going to go ahead and say hide
the lines so with Pinal it's like
layering things so if I have the cartoon
show and then I add lines then I add
sticks I'm adding everything on top of
it so whatever I showed before I can
just hide again so hide my lines here
and now we can just focus in on these
interface residues so we're gonna show
these and don't show as we want it to go
on top if we show as it'll start cutting
out pieces of the secondary structure so
for your interface residues add them on
top show this sticks and now we have all
of our our sticks here so that's pretty
cool and
and and at this point you can really see
if you've like kind of miss some
interactions that might look like
they're between the chains and it looks
you
oh it looks like I'm missing something
right here
okay so I miss this residue now what I'm
gonna do is go back to my interface
residues and add this to my selection so
like all hope isn't lost if you miss
something on the first go so it was this
tyrosine residue right here so I'm just
gonna add that and that should be added
to my to my selection so once that
selection is reselected you can can add
to it and then just click away so you
don't add things you don't want to if
you accidentally click um so now I'm
gonna show sticks again so we again show
the sticks for our interface residues
hopefully we have them all if we don't
at this point I'm not gonna add them in
and just want to kind of give you the
gist of this now let me hide the lines
from here so this is my ace I'm hiding
lines okay now it's a little less busy
and now you can retrace these
interactions now if I can also just go
to the interface residues and do the
actions again find polar context but
when I do to any atoms notice over here
I'm getting polar contacts that are you
know within this selection I really all
I wanted to map was the ones between it
so I'm just gonna turn these off for now
hide those and what I did was now I
entered wizard measurement and I trace
these so for distances you can create a
new object every time you'll end up with
a lot of objects here I like to merge
with previous and then just do a little
set at once so I'm gonna try to just
recreate this and I think when I we use
the measurement wizard my lines will
come up in yellow so I'll be able to
trace and if not I can change that so
I'll show you so it's saying please
click on the first atom and this is
where I want to start so I'm going to go
ahead and click here and then measure
this distance okay and let's see if I
can color these yellow and have them
show up
just yellow okay well I guess it's not
showing up the yellow over that I wish
it was but we can go ahead and just
trace this and we can just do this area
we could do them all as one selection or
we could do it in little chunks when I
can kind of see my yellow lines I
thought I thought that that might be a
slick trick and I could make this
measurement a little bit easier but it
looks like the magenta ones are showing
up better but no seen the the angstrom
numbers come up when you use the
measurement wizard and so you can use
that to know if you've actually traced
over and kind of keep track so I'm just
gonna move along here do these all as
one object so you've got kind of a
double interaction going on this is a
carboxylate so it's interacting we don't
know really which oxygen it's
interacting through they're both
equidistant so probably both because you
know it's a carboxylate as has a
resonant structure and the resonance
structures are just an average of the
structure if you're not too strong with
organic chemistry that might be a little
confusing okay so see I did this 23.7
and now I have to delete all my
measurements um so it may be better to
do this and in little chunks yeah since
I'm merging with previous this is gonna
delete everything yeah so let's just do
one unit do do we head that one down
okay and then we'll say done and now we
have measure one and so now we can so we
don't want to mess up like I did last
time and measure something in the
distance and so we can go back to the
measurement wizard and we're gonna click
on the merge with previous I think this
should create a new measurement though
oh I guess it's still adding to measure
one so we can change this if we want let
me just show you that to create new
object and then if we mess up it's not a
big deal but we get a lot of selections
and I get a little crazy so see this is
measured
- now the next thing I do over here will
be measure three and so you know it just
makes a lot more selections and I like
to keep this a little bit neat I don't
know maybe you can merge sigh oh see so
I messed up measure five and so I'm
going to go ahead and delete last object
no problem because it wasn't all of my
objects and so we can just go through
and find the interactions to these
residues we've shown as sticks let's see
oh and this stuff over here hey that's
really great so this loop is making
these polar contacts now this doesn't
find hydrophobic contacts um you can
find any context you can find residues
around or residue and so if something
looks like it's closed you could look
for nearby residues but I don't want to
go into that today that's not what I did
to create this image for the video so
alright so we've got a bunch of our
contacts all set up and so I could turn
off these interface polar context and
notice we're losing all this stuff over
here but we have everything at the or
most things at the interface hopefully I
got enough of them just to kind of
illustrate this for you and I did label
the residues and I move the labels if
you're interested in that I have a short
labeling video that shows you how to
move these so they're not on the lines
they're a little bit over and resize the
numbers which is really nice but if
you're just modeling this and you want
to kind of examine what's going on here
this is one way that you can do it and
if you've come up with any tricks do
leave me a note in the comments I want
to show you one more really cool
interaction that I wasn't able to show
you in my Tsarskoe - video because the
paper wasn't out at the time and I just
missed this interaction I didn't quite
look for anything like this but it's
really interesting so I want to show you
so I actually had to go back to what I
called a Stu la Swan and RBD one over
here to show this
and so what we're gonna do is find
asparagine 90 now and so here's 91 and
so here's our asparagine 90 and this is
glycosylated and so we can see
asparagine 90 and the two sugars so let
me go ahead and rename this selection
ASN 90 and i can see there's a series of
sugars hanging off of it and so I'm
gonna select those as well
and we'll make them their own selection
so we'll rename this to sugars so this
is Sparrow genus glycosylated as I did
mention in the video let me go ahead and
hide all these lines it gets so busy
with them on there and now I'm gonna
show this asparagine as sticks I'm going
to show the sugars attached to it as
sticks and I don't want them green I
just want to really highlight them so I
want to see them a little bit
differently and actually let me show
this RBD I am going to show the lines
for this because what I'm going to show
you is another interaction that's
actually going to occur through the
sugars that are appended over here so
that's a really neat interaction um so
let me color these by element I'm gonna
do them in white to highlight them and
now we can go ahead and let's find
actions find their polar contacts pull
their contacts to any atoms and so look
at this right here and now let's
highlight this so we have this one polar
contact let me show this residue as
sticks
and for this polar contact I'm actually
going to just go ahead and show the
labels and so I'll show us how long this
interaction is and then let me just go
ahead and hide the lines since we don't
need them anymore and let's try to zoom
on I think we can zoom on this boom okay
there we go
kind of faded it out so I'll take off
this clipping
so the sugar is actually making a polar
contact to this arginine residue on the
RBD over here so that ace is
glycosylated with three sugars and one
of those is involved in another type of
interphase interaction and I couldn't
show you this on the side that we were
looking at because it didn't have the
three sugars so I guess this interaction
is only present on this side and that's
why I had to kind of jump over to show
this to you well I hope this tutorial
helped you to at least be able to
navigate how to find interactions when
you know you don't have a paper for the
crystal structure or if you're just
looking at something and you kind of
want to see the interactions on your own
without looking at the paper or maybe
they don't talk too much about a certain
interface and you want to model it I
have a lot more videos on primal that'll
show you how to make movies like this
will show you how to label your residues
so you can go check out that series if
you're interested in making pretty
videos like this one thanks for watching